I got people I got supplement companies
mad at me left and right here because I
can't take a joke okay what do you
people nuts Who do you think said get
taking your product out there when you
start micromanaging your audience when
you start demanding your audience be
upstanding moral people it is the
quickest route to bankruptcy listen to
me now you non-mainstream
people when you start demanding purity
of your audience I'm telling you right
now it is the quickest rout to
bankruptcy Whoever likes it can like it
they're allowed to like it if it appeals
there are people listening to the show
right now in
Hamas that is a fact you may not like it
I don't love everything they do I think
some of it's somewhat
creative But I me I mean just just from
afar I don't love it I would I don't
endorse it at all you know what I mean I
I I don't like tunnels at all really I I
don't even like
them uh you know I never I I didn't like
water parks really but the point is that
I'm saying that I cannot go around and
make sure that everybody who enjoys my
content is a perfect moral up but some
of these advertisers and I won't mention
names some of these advertisers are
demanding that everybody who says
something nice about their product be
like perfect and I'm telling you right
now it is the quickest route to
destroying yourself I'm telling you I've
seen it before especially when you have
a digital marketing strategy if your
company is
Coca-Cola it's not but if it is perhap
and by the way how many people drink a
Coke and then shoot their wife in the
head a lot a lot of people a lot of
people have a can of Pepsi and then
sexually abuse their own
children and I'm not saying it's right
what I'm saying is that Pepsi is in the
business of selling Pepsi they're not in
the business of finding out who's
pedophile they're not in the business of
finding out who's beating their wife you
know some people take a Heineken and
Bash it over the head of someone else is
that heineken's fault no it's
not read into this what you want I'm not
getting specific I'm just saying that I
I am giving advice to people out there
I'm telling you right now Purity leads
to bankruptcy okay